[Musik]
wolfram liebe mitbürgerinnen mit
gewehren und die leute die mich zum
tanzen gebracht haben ist liebe menschen
in delaware
ich sehe tom popper da unten und auch
senat das tun so sabrina ist glaube ich
auch da bist du das und der frühere
gewinner und männer und sein schlichter
meine schwester valery ist auch da nun
ja die menschen dieser nationen haben
gesprochen und uns einen klaren sieg
beschert einen überzeugenden sieg für
uns das volk wir haben mit der meisten
stimmen gewonnen
die jemals einen präsidentenkandidatin
dieser nation bekommen hat 74 millionen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich muss gestehen es hat nicht
überrascht dass wir in diese nation in
allen städten in allen teilen
überall auf der welt freude hoffnung
sehen ein vertrauen in das morgen dass
ein bessere zeit bringen kann
[Applaus]
ich bin tief bewegt von dem vertrauen
und dass sie ihn nicht gesetzt haben
ich habe versprochen ein präsident zu
sein der nicht spaltet sondern ein der
keine roten bundesstaates oder blaue
sondern nur die vereinigten staaten mit
meinem ganzen herzen setze ich auf das
vertrauen aller menschen und ich hoffe
ihr vertrauen gewinnen zu können und das
vertrauen in das worum es in amerika
geht und die menschen und das wird
unsere regierung im auge behalten
ich wollte dieses amt um die seele
amerika zurückgegeben zurückzugeben
das rückgrat dieser nation die
mittelklasse aufzubauen und amerika
wieder zu einer respektierten nation in
der welt zu machen
hier zu hause erlebe ich die ehre meines
lebens dass so viele millionen von
amerikanern für diese vision gestimmt
haben und jetzt ist diese vision die
aufgabe unserer zeit schon so oft gesagt
ich bin als ehemann
ich stünde nicht her die liebe und die
komplette unterstützung meiner ehefrau
ziel und meine songs einer meiner
tochter aller meiner enkel und deren
ehepartner und deren familien sind in
meinem herzen meine mutter die ihr leben
dieser aufgabe sind nicht hass und die
wie meine frau für das amerikanische
erziehungswesen arbeitet das ein großer
tag für dieses erziehungswesen
sie haben mit ihr auch eine stimme im
weißen haus als first lege ich bin so
stolz auf die ich habe die ehre
mit einer fantastischen vize-präsidentin
arbeiten zu können sie haben sie gerade
gehört ist als kammerherr es die
geschichte schreiben als erste frau als
erste schwarze frau aus südostasien aus
asien als erste tochter eines
einwanderers die vizepräsident wird in
diesem land sagt hier nicht es ist nicht
möglich in den vereinigten staaten
[Applaus]
es war lange fällig und ich möchte damit
auch an diejenigen erinnern die so hart
so viele jahre dafür gekämpft haben dass
es wahr wird amerika möchte mehr
gerechtigkeit und carla ihre familie die
steht dafür da gibt es kein zurück alle
die die mitgearbeitet haben als
freiwillige als wahlhelfer inmitten
dieser pandemie die offiziellen in den
städten
ihr habt den dank der gesamten nation
verdient
mein wahlkampfteam alle freiwilligen
alle die so viel von sich selbst gegeben
haben um diesen augenblick möglich zu
machen
ich schulde euch dankbarkeit ich schulde
euch alles alle diejenigen die uns
unterstützt haben
ich bin stolz auf den wahlkampf den wir
geführt haben
auf die koalition die wir zusammen
gebracht haben die wirklich diverseste
koalition der geschichte demokraten
republikaner progressive konservative
junge menschen alte u bahnen menschen
menschen vom land weise latinos asiaten
alle sind amerikaner
speziell in diesen augenblicken als der
wahlkampf wirklich den tiefpunkt
erreicht hatte da stand die afrikanische
community auf und hat ihre stimme
erhoben
und ich bekam ihre stimmen
ich sagte zu beginn
ich möchte dass in diesem wahlkampf
deutlich wird amerika aussieht und die
regierung die wir haben werden
ich verstehe die trump unterstützt haben
aber jetzt geben wir uns gegenseitig
doch eine chance
[Applaus]
es ist an der zeit die harsche rhetorik
aufzugeben einander wiederzusehen wieder
zuzuhören wenn wir in unseren gegnern
keine feinde sehen
sie sind keine feinde sie sind
amerikaner
amerikanische mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger
bibel sagt es gibt eine zeit für alles
seine zeit zum aufbau einer zeit zum
heilen und jetzt ist die zeit zum
heiligen amerika gekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist der wahlkampf vorbei
was ist jetzt der wille des volkes was
ist unser mandat aber ich denke dass
folgende die amerikaner dies soll von
uns dass wir an stand zeigen dass wir
fairness zeigen dass wir die
wissenschaft voranbringen und die
hoffnung in diesen schweren kämpfen
unserer zeit dass wir das virus
kontrollieren dass wir den kampf und
wohlstand führen um die sicherheit der
gesundheit ihrer familien und umzusehen
rassen gerechtigkeit und den kampf gegen
den systemischen rassismus in diesem
land ein und kampf unseren planeten zu
schützen indem wir das klima unter
kontrolle bringen den kampf den anstand
wieder herzustellen
die demokratie zu verteidigen und jedem
in diesem land eine faire chance zu
geben
das ist alles was wir wollen eine faire
chance unsere arbeit gut unter kontrolle
zu bringen hat bereits bekommen wir
müssen wieder die vitalität unserer
wirtschaft her stellen für unsere kinder
für unsere enkelkinder
für all diese augenblicke die uns so
wichtig sind
bis wir das alles unter kontrolle haben
ich werde am montag eine gruppe von
führenden wissenschaftlern und experten
als berater für diese übergangsphase
ernennen und die werden diese beiden
harris kampagne gegen das virus führen
die dann am zwanzigsten januar mit
unserer amtszeit weiter geschürt wird
meine familie stützt sich auf handfeste
wissenschaft auf empathie und mit
fühlen und wir werden keine keine
bemühung auslassen
in unserer entschlossenheit diese
pandemie aufzuhalten und zu stoppen
ich bin ein stolzer demokrat aber ich
werde regieren als amerikanischer
präsident
ich werde auch hart arbeiten für die die
nicht für mich gestimmt haben
genauso wie für die die für mich
gestimmt haben lassen sie uns aufhören
mit dieser dämonisierung in amerika hier
und jetzt damit schluss machen
[Applaus]
die weigerung dass demokraten und
republikaner nicht miteinander arbeiten
können dass wir eine entscheidung die
wir uns entschieden haben
wir haben uns entschieden dass der
tunnel trennen wir sagen wir wollen
kooperieren dann tun wir das ich glaube
das gehört es um mandat dass uns das
amerikanische volk gegeben hat ist das
will dass wir kooperieren in seinem
interesse und das sind die
entscheidungen die wir treffen im
kongress demokraten die republikaner
sollte diese entscheidung mit mir
treffen die amerikanische geschichte
wird bedeutet dass wir chancen schaffen
wollen in amerika und während sie sich
nicht es sind zu viele fehler gemacht
worden werden müssen wirklich diese
versprechungen in diesem land für alle
wieder real machen egal welchen glauben
welche überzeugung sie haben welche
behinderung liebe mittleren mitbürger in
amerika hat es immer wendepunkte sie
geben in der geschichte und immer
schwerer entscheidungen bezüglich dessen
was wir sind und was wir sein wollen
1860 hat linken die union retten wollen
1932 gab es den new deal gfk hat 1960
auch wieder eine neue ära eingeleitet
und vor zwölf jahren hat barack obama
history geschrieben geschichte
geschrieben mit seinem yes we can
[Musik]
wir stehen jetzt an einem wendepunkt wir
haben die chance die verzweiflung zu
enden und ein ziel und einen zweck
wieder vor augen zu haben
ich habe darüber gesprochen wie die
seele amerikas belastet ist wir müssen
die seele amerikas wiederherstellen
unsere nation ist geprägt vom ständigen
kampf zwischen unseren besseren seiten
und den dunklen seiten und das was der
präsident in diesem kampf sagt hat
bedeutung es geht um die besseren zeiten
die besseren instinkte die vorherrschen
müssen
heute schaut die ganze welt auf amerika
und ich glaube an das beste in uns
amerika ist ein leuchtturm für die welt
wir sind nicht nur ein beispiel für die
macht sondern unser beispiel gibt uns
macht
ich glaube schon immer daran und ich
habe es immer gesagt dass man amerika in
einem wort ausdrücken kann möglichkeiten
das in amerika jeder die gelegenheit
bekommt seine träume zu verwirklichen
und die ihm gott gegebenen fähigkeiten
zu verwirklichen
ich glaube an diese möglichkeiten in
diesem land wir schauen immer nach vorn
wir schauen immer dahin wo wir ein
gerechteres amerika mehr arbeitsplätze
würde und respekt schaffen können
wir schauen in die zukunft auch in
amerika das niemanden zurück lässt in
die zukunft auf ein amerika das nie
aufgibt
[Applaus]
eine große nation und wir sind gute
menschen das sind die vereinigten
staaten von amerika und es hat nie etwas
gegeben von dem wir gesagt haben das
können wir nicht schaffen so lange wir
zusammen gestalten sind in den letzten
tagen des wahlkampfs habe ich darüber
nachgedacht was wirklich wichtig auch
für mich bedeutete mein sohn und das
bedeutet auch für mich dass ich an das
glauben was amerika auf macht und ich
hoffe dass das auch vertrauen darin
schafft dass diese tausende von amerika
die durch diese schreckliche virus ist
schon familienangehörige verloren haben
mein herz ist bei ihnen allen
ich hoffe es gibt ihnen auch ein
bisschen tröstung und er wird sicherlich
auch dafür einstehen dass sie im grunde
in seinen helden aufgehoben sind auf
diesem weg den gott und die geschichte
von uns erwarten
mit festen hin mit fester hand und
entschlossenem herz mit der liebe zu
unserem land und dem respekt vor der
gerechtigkeit das ist unsere nation von
dem wir denken dass sie so sein kann
eine geeinte nation eine starke nation
eine geheilte nation die vereinigten
staaten von amerika meine damen und
herren es hat nie etwas gegeben was wir
nicht schaffen konnten
ich erinnere mich an mein großvater als
ich aus seinem haus ging und er zu mir
sagte joe bleibt zuversichtlich und
behalte den glauben und meine mutter
meine großmutter sagten einbehalten
nicht verbreite den glauben
gott möge uns und unsere zukunft
schützen
ich danke ihnen
[Musik]